OLIVIER DE WECK:
Assessing student work
as a team has
different challenges.
Of course, the
first thing you do
is assess the output
of the team's work,
whether that's a
requirements set,
whether it's a set
of initial concepts,
whether it's a
presentation that's
given at a preliminary
design review,
whether it's a physical
prototype that they present
as a team--
so that always should be the
first thing that is assessed
is, what is the net output
that the team has produced?
Within that, it is not
always easy to discern
what has been the
individual contribution
since the whole
purpose of the team
is that the sum that
comes out is greater
than the individual parts.
So in the
best-functioning teams,
there is a magic that happens.
There's a synergy that happens.
There's an output
that's only produced
by these synergistic
interactions of all the team
members.
In a sense, trying
to dissect, what's
the individual piece
that everybody did,
is countering this
idea of team synergy.
That being said, we also
need to assess individually
the contributions and the
learnings of students.
And we do this through
a couple of mechanisms,
for example, a peer review.
So you can do a
peer-review process.
It's trickier in smaller
teams than in larger teams.
But if it's done
properly, peer review
can be very effective in not
only helping one understand,
who are the contributors?
And who are the free-riders?
This is always a
big issue in teams,
is that the free-rider
syndrome, where
some team members contribute
significantly less than others.
And this often can be
a source of conflict.
And so understanding
this is important.
But also, have other
mechanisms in the class,
such as an individual
final exam, and then
the other written exam,
which is administered online.
And the other thing
we started doing
is oral exams, which
seems old-fashioned.
But I have to tell you,
in 15 to 20 minutes
of a one-on-one
conversation with a student
at the end of the class,
you really learn a lot.
You learn a lot
about what they've
learned, where they may
still have confusion
or misconceptions, and also the
feedback that they give you.
So I highly recommend to do
oral exams if it's possible.